[Music]
morning everybody seven o'clock here in
the uk very welcome to spend your
breakfast with us here at sky news as
the race to get people out of kabul
continues this morning we'll ask whether
the uk's newly announced resettlement
program for afghan citizens
goes far enough the home secretary priti
patel says the uk is doing everything
possible to support those in need she's
here in the studio in just a moment then
at 20 past eight general cynic carter
the head of the british military will
also be here giving us his view on how
the taliban was able to stage its
takeover it's wednesday the 18th of
august
flown to safety more evacuation flights
arrived from kabul as human rights
groups criticized government plans to
resettle 20 000 afghan citizens
i'm here at raf bryce norton in
oxfordshire where another flight landed
last night
back to the bench's mps to return to
parliament this morning three days after
the taliban took to the afghan capital
senior taliban leaders returned to
afghanistan from exile in qatar as talks
continue over how the new government
will function
the taliban is trying to present a new
image to the world promising women's
rights and amnesty for opponents but
does the global community believe them
good morning the weather across the uk
in ireland then rather cloudy cool with
some drizzly rain but there will be some
sunny spells as well i'll bring you all
the details through the morning
[Music]
let's get straight to it should we the
um home secretary is with me here in the
studio of course pretty patel tell us
about this resettlement program good
morning kay so this is absolutely about
our commitment to
people in afghanistan who are vulnerable
in light of what we are now seeing with
scenes on the ground so this is
effectively a new humanitarian route a
resettlement scheme that obviously is
coming in addition to the work that we
are doing right now to remove afghan
nationals who've worked with our armed
forces and done all sorts of incredible
work alongside the british government
over the last 20 years so this route
will in the first year we are speaking
first of all about the first year will
bring approximately 5 000 people from
afghanistan to the united kingdom we're
working through details the logistics
that party partners that we'll be
working through
and the real details of that will come
together over the next few days does 5
000 this year reflect accurately the
scenes that we've seen at kabul airport
well i think it's important kay to
ensure that we have a scheme that will
deliver
and we have to think very carefully
about the practicalities currently
already and you would have heard from my
colleague ben wallace ben and i have
been working in the defense secretary
and i've been working very close on
bringing back resettling those afghan
nationals who've worked alongside
british forces we'll talk about that
separately so that's one scheme and
that's around five thousand people in
fact that's going to be bigger so
importantly with the new humanitarian
route that we are announcing today we
have to ensure that we have clearly all
the support structures
across the united kingdom so you would
have seen from our announcement we'll be
working with local councils around the
country with the devolved governments as
well to ensure that we can support those
people this isn't just about bringing
people over this is about resettlement
resettling people so that they can begin
a new life in the united kingdom if you
don't do it quickly they might not be
alive well we are working quickly on
this so why not twenty thousand all at
once primarily because we cannot
accommodate twenty 000 people all in one
go we have to have this well actually i
spoke to the canadians last night came
they can't okay so what do they say to
you so i will tell you now what they've
said they have an aspiration for 20 000
people and that also includes their
locally employed staff so we are talking
about this new scheme in addition to the
work that we are doing with locally
employed staff and other categories that
will be included in the repatriation
flights that you're seeing currently
we're bringing back almost a thousand
people a day and when it comes to
locally employed staff we've already
brought over 2 000 people back since
june this year and we've had 13 charter
flights bringing people back so look
this is an enormous effort but i think
also there are some really important
points to just highlight right now for
viewers we can't do this on our own no
country no government can do this on
their own so i spoke to my five eyes
counterparts last night we have to work
together
the americans clearly they are in
afghanistan they're working with us and
our military in terms of securing the
airport helping to facilitate people to
get them out of kabul get them out of
afghanistan and in our case take them to
different locations and then come to the
uk but the international community has
to work together on this and it's not
about one country saying we're going to
do x we're all working together to
really save lives and this is
effectively what we are doing with our
scheme but also recognizing the
international work that we're all
undertaking which locations
until they're coming out to separate
locations so america are using different
bases and different stations what do we
do so we're working we have a hub in
dubai so that is effectively where our
planes often stop to refuel where also
we do a lot of our additional checks we
have to check people before they come to
the united kingdom so that's
verification of documentation national
security checks are incredibly important
as a government we must always ensure
that we are bringing over people that
have passed all national security checks
extension island so
that
this is we're we're talking about dubai
right now just in terms of the mod work
which other areas they might be coming
to well i don't not from not from our
perspective other countries and other
governments will do what they they will
do effectively and that's the matter for
them but from the uk perspective we are
bringing as you've seen the flights come
in straight from afghanistan with
refueling stops in places like dubai
straight over to bryce norton when will
the first plane carrying the afghan
refugees that we're talking about today
on this scheme when will they arrive in
the uk well we're working on that
because our priority right now is
british nationals we have to ensure that
we get all british nationals out of
afghanistan and alongside that we have
the locally employed staff and over the
last three weeks we've been adding to
categories as well of other individuals
who are vulnerable who are yes those
that have been locally employed not just
working with the military but but also
for example other categories
people that have worked with ngos civil
society there are many many others
including you know family dependents so
we've been working very hard they have
been our focus and as i've already said
kay our plans right now they are being
developed because we have to ensure that
we've got the accommodation for them
when they come here and that also we
have the right civil society partners
when do you have to ensure that the
scheme comes together when do you
anticipate the people that we're talking
about right now these african refugees
as part of the 20 000 in total when do
you expect the first of those to arrive
in the uk well we're working through
that right now i'm not going to give you
a date but we don't know at this stage
well it's not okay to say you don't know
if you don't well actually we're working
through it so i'm not going to give a
date and a cup one out of three we're
working with partners and you've already
heard me saying there'll be there'll be
a call to local authorities around the
country and many other partners that
have experience i think it's important
to say as a country we've done
phenomenal work when it comes to
resettlement schemes when you look at
the syrian vulnerable person scheme as
well that included community sponsorship
all sorts of third party organizations
in communities that welcome reset um
refugees resettle them but also we have
to put the welfare support the education
support and all the others can wrap
around supports
that's what we're working okay so now so
how are we going to get these people out
of afghanistan given that the taliban
say that they don't want to uh any uh
afghans to leave the country well i
think are they not people that are in
afghanistan no this is an international
effort first of all i think we have to
we have to have some perspective here
we've all seen the scenes in terms of
what is going on on the ground this is a
very fluid situation we have military
forces on the ground and you know it's
the uk forces armed forces as well as
the us and there are other partners as
well we are working with in terms of
facilitating people to get them you know
through intercontinental
if well this is an international effort
okay this is this is my point it's not
about the taliban saying that they're
not allowing us to take them because
that's inaccurate that is absolutely
inaccurate right now we are working
internationally through our past
well the talibans are saying certain
things we can see right now we're
working on the ground to get people
afghan nationals are on flights every
single day okay they are coming through
they're landing at bryce norton along
with british nationals so they are
coming through it is a logistical
operation through military partners and
other partners on the ground to ensure
that we get people out and there are
plans in place to do that so this is
this is this is not this is not clinical
at all this is difficult it is involving
a lot of resource on the ground
it's a very complicated fluid situation
but it's also a fluid situation what
about the afghan nationals who've
managed to leave the country and go to
third-party countries like i don't know
pakistan will they be counted as part of
these twenty thousand well look we're
going to work across the board and we're
working with all international partners
so you'll be very aware you've just
raised pakistan our prime minister has
already been in touch with imran khan
the prime minister of pakistan we have
to look at all of this now not just from
the i mean afghanistan is incredibly
important but regional stability and
security in the region so pakistan does
not want instability in their own
country so this is my point about
international cooperation and
collaboration we are working we are in
touch with all our allies it's important
that we are united and coordinated in
our collective efforts to get people out
not just of afghanistan but people who
need protection people who are fleeing
oppression persecution whose lives are
at risk and that does take an
international effort okay let me just
say now the british government will work
with every partner to ensure that we can
do the right thing by those that need
our help and support exactly the taliban
well we have to work internationally in
terms of cooperation we'll work with all
our allies we'll work with all our
allies to ensure you've already heard me
speak and reference certain countries so
i've mentioned pakistan i've mentioned
canada five eyes so i was speaking to my
five eyes counterpart
well we we have to we have to work with
all partners partners international
partners i should say our partners that
have worked in the region to bring
stability and security and to bring
protection let me ask you about it we
have continued to do that okay also hope
to see if i'm there we only have a
limited amount of time what about the
afghan nationals who've recently crossed
the channel and have found themselves
seeking asylum in the uk
could they be part of the 20 000 well
i'm speaking very specifically no
they're not if i if i can just without
jumping to conclusions curve already
said that we're working on this scheme
our priority right now with the new
scheme for the f 5000 specifically we do
want to prioritize women girls and the
most vulnerable persecuted minorities
when it comes to others that have come
through illegal migration rules we will
have to look at those cases and the way
in which we do anyway through the asylum
system we are reforming the asylum
system but there's an important point to
make here right now when the world and
when we see what we are seeing in
afghanistan when we see harrowing scenes
when we know that there is a
humanitarian crisis unfolding in front
of us it's right that we create bespoke
routes humanitarian routes to protect
lives but those are governments that
fled across the channel and are now
seeking asylum from afghanistan they did
that you know of course there's a
distinction okay there is a distinction
between those illegal routes where
people have been trafficked through
um
gangs and criminal activities
if i may say so you won't know the
background to many of those cases and
these are people that have come through
illegally currently we are creating a
new bespoke scheme which rightly so
focuses on women and girls many of those
women and girls are minorities are
pushed aside as we have seen
historically in afghanistan but also
when it comes to claiming asylum in many
countries
and if i may finally just say on people
that have come to the united kingdom
legally they're also traveling through
many safe countries through eu member
states and i am calling on all my
international counterparts other
interior ministers to work collectively
together with that responsibility on
this with that in mind do you agree with
president macron that europe i'm quoting
him um can't bear the consequences and
we need to protect ourselves against
migration well president macron you know
will make those types of comments we
agree with them well what i would say
though
there is a crisis there is a
humanitarian crisis the united kingdom
is creating new humanitarian routes to
ensure that we can save lives and
protect people
within europe there is so much more that
the eu commission can do and could do in
terms of stopping irregular migration
and creating safe and legal routes and
to disagree with to be very frank i've
also been
persuaded as persuading and speaking to
other eu member states over recent
months to effectively ask them to do
much more on the humanitarian side and
support the creation of safe and legal
routes which could stem flows of the
illegal people you were talking about
the different uh scheme as well that
involves the interpreters and third
party contractors johnny mercer one of
your mps says that the figure of 5000 um
doesn't even touch the sides he says
it's something like 20 000 people
who should be caught up in that scheme
how do we choose which
000 to leave behind well i think first
of all
this is we this is a scheme that has
been developed in conjunction with the
mod
and the home office ben wallace and i
have worked together on this and this is
a scheme that was announced in april and
as you've already heard me say since
june the 22nd of june um up until last
week we brought over 2000 people so
these are locally employed staff
and other countries are doing exactly
the same with lds schemes now the mod
have their own processes they know
exactly who they've been working with
translators interpreters and there'll be
many others as well in terms of
resilient staff on the ground what i
would say is that the mod have been
incredible in terms of the scheme the
development of the scheme and we support
that obviously in terms of documentation
and giving people um the status
recognizing them the checks to then come
to the united states
well actually
but if you've heard what i've said
already i'm listening to every step
that's that scheme has been expanded
yeah um so there are more categories
that so we don't there'll be more than
five thousand we're already seeing more
than one ten thousand there could be up
to ten thousand but not twenty thousand
so they're happy up to the other
so let me just be clear about this there
could be up to ten thousand we are
expanding categories right now of people
and we're working with
the mod on the ground we're working with
partners on the ground to identify these
individuals and importantly so there
could be more than ten there could be
there absolutely could be and if you
think about the flights that we're
seeing on a daily basis with up to a
thousand people coming back you can see
that more and more people we are working
night and day
we have people we're being very fluid
and very flexible i'm sure johnny
and also in addition to that when you
think about the additional staff we've
got the mod the military teams on the
ground i'm sending in home office
officials who put border force officials
into the region to help support this
scheme as well okay so we're being very
fluid and we're recognizing the change
in nature and the landscape of what is
going on this is not clear-cut it's not
binary it's not clinical it's great i'm
sure we're doing everything possible to
ensure that we can save lives and
recognize that there are many
individuals whose lives are at risk
right now because quite frankly they've
stood by us they've stood by our country
over the last 20 years and we are
working night and day to do the right
thing to try and protect them and bring
them to the united kingdom we're almost
out of time i know you have an awful lot
of people to talk to this morning so we
appreciate you taking the time to join
us let me ask you quickly before i let
you go um as a woman as well as a
politician but primarily as a woman you
heard what the taliban was saying
yesterday
how much of what they said did you
believe
well
not just particularly when it comes to
women well they were saying well let's
let's let's put everything about the
taliban into context when it comes to
women and i have been to afghanistan and
i have seen how oppressed the level of
oppression that women and girls have
been subjected to in afghanistan
and look one of the strongest aspects of
all our work and the british
government's commitment and the
international community's commitment
over the last 20 years there's no
question being the work around women and
girls it's been extraordinary was it all
for nothing though we are doing the
right thing in my view through the new
routes that we are creating we're
putting women and girls and vulnerable
people first it will for anybody that
has served in afghanistan people and
also in the international community that
have been there they will totally
recognize just the level of oppression
the fear and persecution that women have
been subject to and girls and we want to
prevent that which is why
you'll see from the prime minister
you'll hear from the prime minister
today and i worked with i worked with
the prime minister when he was foreign
secretary i saw the commitment that he
gave to women and girls
in afghanistan and around the world we
stand by all the work that we have put
in place the protections and we are
committed to doing so much more so i
think you know the taliban's actions
were so emotional
i've seen it i've absolutely seen in
afghanistan the level of oppression and
persecution of women and girls and it's
unspeakable
are we doing the right thing by pulling
out our troops following the united
states well we are where we are okay
look we are where we are on all of this
and our objective right now as a
government is to save lives and do the
right thing when it comes to the
humanitarian approach that we take but i
think and i recognize this in many many
ways i've been to refugee camps in
jordan in lebanon we've seen the
conflict the level of conflict that
afghanistan the destabilization that we
have all witnessed over the last 20
years
it is appalling we want to save lives we
stand by that we stand by those women
and girls who've been subject to
oppression and persecution
and my final point is the international
community this is an enormous moment for
the international community it was only
you know seven eight years ago we saw
what happened in syria we have to work
together and it's part of my own plea to
my colleagues within the five eyes
community last night as well we have to
speak with one voice we have to work
together we have to support each other
no country can deliver
humanitarian support or support for
women and girls we can't do it on our
own we have to absolutely stick together
and work together to save lives and
protect protect those afghan nationals
whose lives are at risk i have to let
you go are you okay
thanks for joining us
uh let's take you to rf rise norton
aisha standing by for us hello to you
aisha expecting more flights in today
yeah that's right expect more flights
today and over the next few days as well
we've seen hundreds of people arrive
since the weekend and the most recent
flight touched down here last night it
arrived at raf bryce norton at around 11
p.m and it was an raf voyager carrying
not only british nationals but afghan
nationals as well
and we expect to see another flight
arrive today around 350 more people
expected within the next 24 hours as
well the british armed forces are hoping
to evacuate between six to seven
thousand people from afghanistan and
that includes
british nationals as well as selected
afghans as well people who have
previously worked with british forces
and we know
that more troops were also deployed from
here to go and assist the evacuation and
to help maintain control at kabul
airport
okay thank you
still to come on the program four you
have past seven we'll be joined from
pakistan by ahmad wali masood
afghanistan's former ambassador to the
uk
quarter to eight will speak to
historians anthony selton to discuss the
significance of parliament's emergency
sitting today
at hapa state we'll get labor's view on
the afghan resettlement scheme when i'm
joined by the shadow foreign secretary
lisa nandi
[Music]
taliban has given the first news
conference since taking power promising
and amnesty for those who had opposed
them and saying women's rights will be
respected as the group's leaders arrived
in afghanistan from exile in qatar they
asked for the people and the
international community to trust them
and their new islamic emirate meanwhile
in the west boris johnson and joe biden
spoke over the telephone and made plans
to hold a virtual g7 meeting next week
our chief correspondent stuart ramsey
reports from kabul
it wouldn't be remarkable if it wasn't
for the fact that this is a taliban
press conference 20 years ago tv was
banned here anyone caught even watching
was arrested and punished
now in the grand surroundings of the
country's presidential palace in front
of a white taliban flag they effectively
announced the new islamic emirate of
afghanistan
their leadership is trying to convince
the world that they are new taliban
rebranded to play a role in the
international community
we assure the people of kabul that there
will be no excesses against them and
they will live in peace
have given great sacrifices
for the establishment of an islamic
government and they have the right to
implement
sharia islamic government in afghanistan
questions as well from the media and the
first to a female journalist in an open
setting unheard of her question women's
rights what assurances can you give to
women and girls that their rights will
be protected we recognize the rights of
the women which islam gave them
women can work they can go to the school
they work they can work in schools they
can work in hospitals
we assure the world that there will be
no excesses
against the women
and everything will be done
under the islamic laws
the taliban vow to uphold women's rights
but within the definition of what they
deem to be compatible with sharia law
clearly they're trying to be reassuring
to a skeptical world
but they are ticking important boxes
like observing the sovereign status of
diplomatic missions we assure the entire
world the people of kabul uh
diplomats living in kabul the the world
bodies the ngos all the organizations
that from now on
no one will be threatened and there will
be no access
against anybody
sure enough the now abandoned british
embassy a large wall complex these days
is locked and guarded humvees parked
outside and apparently at least
untouched
across kabul the taliban continue
patrolling the streets in their familiar
pickup trucks they're here to keep order
but they allowed another first
a women's rights rally this is frankly
astonishing mainly because it wasn't
broken up as they chanted slogans like
don't kill women and afghan women exist
this is all in stark contrast to the
chaos in the airport district of the
city as people try to make their escape
they're determined to get inside the
airport but it is terribly dangerous
inside the repatriation flights are
underway people waiting on the apron to
be loaded onto transporter planes
these are all just abandoned weapons the
breakdown of order here is all too clear
there's an arm store that's been simply
abandoned i could just grab an ak if i
wanted one
as a new government takes shape the men
who will lead it arrived in kandahar
from their mission in qatar
the final piece in the jigsaw of the new
regime
stuart ramsey sky news kabul
i'm at least correspondent ali bunkel
joining us now hello to alastair we were
hearing uh from the home secretary i'm
sure you caught a lot of what she had to
say
no detail yet as to the 20 000 people
that will becoming part of this a new
repatriation scheme but increasing the
numbers that can come with interpreters
families and third-party workers
and she seemed to suggest to you that
there would be some flexibility in that
i think that if you know more people
were identified on the ground in kabul
by the british military then the the
home office would be uh open to uh
increasing the number uh that they'd
already set of around or up to around 10
000
afghans to come to this country uh there
is pressure on the home office to make
sure that um they are sympathetic to the
plight particularly of those afghans who
have worked alongside and for uh the
british government in various different
forms over the last 20 years
particularly in the back of
headlines that suggested that the home
office was trying to
restrict the number of of those afghans
that could come to the uk
i mean
astonishing stuff in uh in in kabul
yesterday as we saw in in stewart's
piece and the and he
uh outlined the taliban giving a press
conference which you know contrasts as
it not with that of joe biden's
statement that he gave to the american
public uh just a couple of nights ago
when he didn't take any questions
whatsoever and of course uh those early
sort of sentiments coming from the group
yeah i mean that you know they sound
like the sort of thing that people want
to be hearing but i would have two major
concerns firstly and stu did touch on it
um exactly how do the taliban of 2021
interpret sharia law particularly uh
with regards to female rights because i
mean you know that is um certainly a
nuanced area where they could uh
severely restrict the liberties away
once again and my seconds of concern is
that that's what we're hearing from the
taliban out of uh kabul out of the
center a bit of history in afghanistan
has told us anything it is almost
impossible to govern the country uh from
a central position uh such as the tribal
framework and uh matrix of afghanistan
and you know i wonder how different
regional uh and local tribes will um
interpret uh their version of what the
taliban want as joseph barrell the eu's
top diplomat said uh they look the same
uh they just speak better english
okay thank you
time for a look at this morning's other
main stories for you so far gas supplies
have been turned off to 50 000 homes in
california where huge fires are still
raging at least two people have been
injured leading to evacuation orders for
thousands of residents and tourists in
el dorado county
the kaldor fire which started over the
weekend has more than doubled in size in
the last two days
43 year old man has been charged in
connection with a social media message
posted after england's defeat in the
euro 2020 final scott mccloskey from
roncorn in cheshire will appear in court
next month the police said the social
media post was written on the 12th of
july the day after england lost to italy
at wembley
officials in haiti say the number of
people known to have died following
saturday's earthquake has risen to 1941.
the crisis has been made worse by a
tropical storm bringing a strong wind
and heavy rain and slowly aid responses
to a slowing i should say aid responses
to people already homeless
weather for you at home here's kirsty
good morning kirsty good
morning good morning to you okay the
weather here looking fairly quiet over
the next few days there's quite a lot of
cloud around but a few glimmers of
sunshine too
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning for many of us it's a
cloudy picture today a west to
northwesterly breeze keeping a little
bit cool and bringing some spots of
drizzly rain mainly to western coasts
and hills parts of eastern scotland
northeast england again looking best for
that sunshine and warmer here in the
sunshine as well up to 23 or 24 but
elsewhere perhaps high teens at best
there's a lot of cloud around and a few
spots and splits of rain nothing too
drastic i think generally speaking it's
a fairly dry rather cloudy picture we
have got a few brighter spells this
afternoon towards parts of the southwest
but eventually we'll see some rain
fringing into parts of cork and kerry
and that's going to push northwards
through the night tonight now tonight
blanket of cloud pretty much everywhere
with again a few more spots of rain
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
so we've been hearing from the home
secretary within the last few moments
she says the number of interpreters and
third parties who helped the brits while
they win in afghanistan that number will
be increased to try to support as many
as we can ahead of the taliban moving in
on the airport at kabul could be
significantly over ten thousand is what
she said we'll have more on that in just
a few moments and also speaking to ahmed
vali masood uh he will be joining us
from uh he's actually the former
ambassador to the uk in uh afghanistan
he's joining us in just a second
[Music]
breaking news in the last few moments
the home secretary has told this program
within the last few minutes that the
number of afghan interpreters offered
resettlement in the uk could double to
up to ten thousand
the mod have been incredible in terms of
the scheme the development of the scheme
and we support that obviously in terms
of documentation and giving people
the status recognizing them the checks
to then come to the united kingdom
well actually as we know okay
but if you've heard what i've said
already i'm listening to every step
that's that scheme has been expanded
yeah um so there are more categories
that so we don't there'll be more than
five thousand we're already seeing more
than ten thousand there could be up to
ten thousand but not twenty thousand so
they're happy up to the other side so
let me just be clear about this there
could be up to ten thousand we are
expanding categories right now of people
and we're working with
the mod on the ground we're working with
partners on the ground to identify these
individuals and importantly so there
could be more than 10 there could be
wow tomorrow yes quite a significant
change there from pretty patel because
we know that the resettlement scheme
that boris johnson will be announcing to
mps today for vulnerable women children
religious minorities which pretty patel
said had suffered unspeakably under the
taliban in the past would now be
resettled in the uk is separate from the
schemes that already run for locally
employed staff so interpreters but they
were also expanded so teachers and
security guards and other people who
worked for western forces in afghanistan
now it was announced today that only 5
000 of them would be coming over on that
scheme some mp saying that leaves people
who worked for the west stuck in
afghanistan at risk of reprisals she
said that if we can it could be over 10
000 people who come over now of course
this depends how much can actually been
delivered how many people can get their
paperwork get to the airport and that's
been very tricky so far but it suggests
that the aspirations for that scheme are
much bigger than has been announced
she's also quite glassy-eyed at this at
the end i've not seen um the home
secretary like that before when she was
talking about women and girls in the
region and what has happened over the
last 72 hours means for them going
forward that's right pretty patel is
seen as a very hard liner on immigration
a lot of
briefings come out of the home office
about
setting up immigration centres in other
parts of the world and we know that she
has a big crackdown against migration
from calais but she points out that she
was international development secretary
in the past she's been to the region she
saw syrians in refugee camps in jordan
and lebanon she says living in terrible
conditions and so she says that she does
understand this issue and and how people
have have suffered
okay for now tomorrow thanks very much
tomorrow's take at nine o'clock see you
then this morning thank you including
what she the home secretary had to say
about president macron uh before that in
their first televised news conference
yesterday we heard from the taliban they
said afghanistan is now emancipated and
claim that everyone is forgiven but
thousands of people are still attempting
to flee the regime triggering what could
be another refugee crisis
joining us now is ahmad wali massoud
afghanistan's former ambassador to the
uk he flew to pakistan for talks with
his country's political leaders on
sunday joins us from islamabad right now
hello to you sir thank you for joining
us on the program do you believe the
taliban when they say they have changed
uh well unfortunately they have not
shown that they have changed because we
are hearing this even today they have
gone to different parts of the city in
kabul to block people's houses
and uh more than any other day today is
really kind of very violent everywhere
spreading up in different cities in
mazar in kabul and different cities
unfortunately that's not what we see
what do we see what are we seeing
because they say they want a peaceful
transition
well we hope to everybody also because
the day the first day that they came
people are scared you have seen on tv
across the world in the media and people
really kind of very fearful and so far
they have not shown that they are kind
of for a smooth transition we hope
probably they may say that well it's
still the dust society let's the dust
will come down then we can do that one
but we hope that their
squats and their groups should stop kind
of violating people's house and property
to go inside different houses to broke
that one we hope to stop that one and
bamiyan did it today and bazaar did it
and global data so everywhere that they
can reach they can do that one so that's
kind of on the contrary what they did
that's
a different contrast really how worried
are you how anxious are you for the fate
of those that worked with the allied
forces during the occupation or however
you want to call it the war the conflict
in afghanistan
well we are worried uh about the fate of
every afghans not only those ones but
every other afghans as well
because it's not that uh they will be in
kind of they should be fearful a lot of
afghans millions of afghans are fearful
so they are kind of very much worried
about the situation about their
appraisal about their revenge about
their
many other things really everyone is
very careful it does appear though i
mean there's a bit of chaos in kabul at
the moment there are roadblocks in place
but there hasn't been the bloodshed that
had been feared
well that's a good sign that the
bloodshed has not been done that's a
very good sign really we hope that it
should not be done in the future on a
few days time or weeks ahead but what's
important now that they should stop the
violence i mean they are supposed to be
emirate and they are supposed to be
responsible for the
safety of the people so they themselves
should not really kind of violate
whatever they have agreed whatever they
have announced the world community
a power
vacuum appears to be in place at least
for now the taliban are very keen to
fill that but one looks towards russia
and also towards china and uh wonder
whether they are keen to do deals with
the taliban what's your interpretation
given that you know the region so
well well i mean they have already
signaled that they can do something
somehow they have signaled out that they
may deal with the taliban but it still
is not known because we have to really
kind of wait and see ahead the days
ahead what exactly is their reaction
they may really try to do so because
they are big powers in the region but
let me say that you know in the region
that's not the only two powers there are
many uh very active players in the
regions but each of them have got their
own interests their own
ideas their own roadmap so let's see how
exactly they all can come in some sort
of consensus to really deliver peace for
afghanistan because don't forget that
for kissing afghanistan the first thing
is that all ethnicities in afghanistan
have reached some sort of consensus on a
mechanism through which every afghan
should really can determine their future
that's the person and the second thing
those countries in the region and exo
region they have to reach consensus on
afghanistan that well we can all help
afghanistan without having a hidden
agenda or interfering with something
like that this is the two pillars that
has to go together if that doesn't
happen then our council will never see
peace but the first and important the
priority for afghanistan is that we
really have to have a system through
which all ethnicities are involved
especially if we can have a political
system through a kind of decentralized
mechanism so every part of our person
can live with their own values under one
afghanistan that's the best option that
we can
we can think of
okay from what you're saying and from
conversations that i've had with others
over the last 72 hours there is a real
concern
about civil war in your country would
you agree
of course at the moment uh you see the
terrible has come
to the palace by force we have not yet
reached the hearts and minds of the
people so it's a long way before we
really say that everything has settled
down so there's a possibility of
everything in afghanistan
talk to me about your brother if you
would ahmed shah massoud a national hero
in afghanistan
for those who don't know him tell us
about him
well he wanted afghanistan for
afghanistan he grew with the people of
afghanistan uh he fought during jihad
against the russian invasion then he
fought against the terrorism of of
course against the torah as well then at
the end of the day he was assassinated
by two
terrorists which belonged to arab
terrors who came and just blew him up
and he stated by all force of the
taliban he said in the northeast of
afghanistan he really resisted the
taliban he
really resisted the terrorists and he
was kind of believed in afghanistan he
believed in today's democracy he
believed in the election he believes in
the
human rights woman right and democracy
all of that he believed that's why that
he was kind of very iconic figure inside
afghanistan and in the region so that is
why now he is not there and one of the
reason why there is comeback of this
situation chaotic situation because he
is not there despite that the world
community helped dr hani to do so but
unfortunately dr rennie was a corrupt
government he had a corrupt government
and the united states really kind of
kind of imposed doctor harry in
afghanistan and that's the reason and
that's the result that we have seen in
afghanistan
um
when will you return to afghanistan do
you think
well we are at the moment and talks
hopefully once we finish the talk then
we will we all the delegation have to
cancel and then we can decide
okay and a thought for the women and
girls in afghanistan
today were being told that they can be
educated up to university level i'm not
sure what happens to them
after that and also i think i'm saying
the taliban said yesterday that they
will have rights under sharia law just
remind us
what rights women have under sharia law
well we have seen their respect sharia
law in the past the taliban have ruled
afghanistan for a few years so we could
see that the girls and their women were
deprived from education if only the
taliban stayed there of course today we
did not have an educated woman and you
hit the girls there unfortunately this
is the same taliban although they may
promise like they promised that they
were not kind of um they have announced
their general amnesty but they violated
the house of the people the same way
they are saying that well we will
respect the right of the woman i'm
pretty sure that their sharia would not
allow the woman to do what exactly
they desire to do so that's very
unfortunate scenario but it's still let
me and
i mean keep our friend across let's see
what happens because it's not possible
that the emirate in afghanistan can work
it's not possible that the very kind of
very restricted interpretation of sharia
in a function would work because
afghanistan for 20 years have seen a new
world so we have got the 70 percent of
young population we have got the women
of afghanistan we have got civil society
all of them really that belong to
geography of resistance against the
value of the taliban so therefore it's
not easy for the tournament to contain
all of them like the past so therefore
then what i mean the conclusion is that
afghanistan problem is a political
problem so therefore that version of the
taliban cannot really provide
the need of the american people good to
talk to you keep well thank you for
joining us
thank you
still to come we speak to the historians
anthony selden to discuss the
significance of this morning's recall of
parliament
[Music]
parliament's been recalled to debate the
situation in afghanistan three days
after the taliban took kabul it's the
first time mp's summer break has been
interrupted for a very long time when
they debated the use of chemical weapons
in syria do you remember when that was
well joining us now is the historian sir
anthony seldon who certainly will he'll
be explaining to us where he is shortly
but before all of that it's good to see
you um anthony thanks for joining us
parliament being recalled not that
common really in the summer
uh not that common okay um
1948 they've been 34 times it tends to
be at moments of great uh national
significance or international crises so
um crises over korea suez northern
ireland 911 the iraq war uh and now
afghanistan or it's uh
for times like the death of major
figures most recently the duke of
edinburgh and margaret saturn 2013 the
labor mp
joe cox or moments of big domestic
importance uh like
the brexit legislation on the 30th of uh
december last year or indeed covered
our regulations in january so
really big moments kay not very popular
mps think they deserve and they do
a summer holiday with their families uh
it means trudging back to them breaking
off their family holidays
and what is the point other than it
being symbolic because there's no vote
today i don't think
uh there's unlikely to be a vote okay uh
it's a chance really
for people to have their say to
acknowledge that this is a major moment
for
uh british history for the families uh
of those soldiers who've
never come back alive
and it's a major political moment 20
years after
almost at 9 11. uh so many british bears
so many international deaths so much
suffering uh what was it all for
what can we take away what consolation
and closure is there
and a sense really across the spectrum
that this is too big a subject not for
parliament both house of lords and house
of commons not to have a say on
so tell me about the mechanics um who
authorizes it who decides how long the
debate is going to be who decides
whether there's going to be a vote or
not at the end
well the house commons is is not the
prime minister's it is uh the mps
themselves in the form of lindsey hoyle
the speaker very powerful figure of the
house of commons it is the speaker's job
uh to recall parliament but can only do
so since 2001
on the advice of ministers and
governments so that's quite a sensitive
subject uh there'll be about five hours
of debate in the house of commons
meeting 9 30 today opened by the prime
minister house of lords some 120
lords want to speak um
they're going to be talking at starting
the more leisurely hour of 11 a.m
sir anthony tell us about why you are in
france today
well uh i'm walking okay from the swiss
border where the western front in the
first world war began uh a thousand
kilometers to the english channel this
was a dream of a british soldier uh who
wrote to his headmaster about
uh after the war he wanted to see
created a path for peace along the line
of the western front the western front
where um uh some uh eight million
soldiers died as a memorial for those
who died just behind me kay you can see
a memorial uh of a father uh telling his
children um there's a book which is on
his
lap
and it's a book that says 1914 to 1918.
and he is telling them uh about the war
and what the war was about and that's of
course a poignant question with the iraq
debate today many people asking uh what
was uh sorry the afghanistan debate
today what was the afghanistan war uh 20
years all about
okay um good luck how far are you how
much further do you have to go
750 kilometers together
and along the way so many cemeteries and
memorials uh dip to war so this is a a
walk for peace a reminder of where war
leads okay hopefully you'll be able to
touch in with us um from time to time
and let us know how you're getting on it
would be great to hear from you
i'd love to do that okay thank you okay
so anthony thank you and thanks for your
expertise about what's going to happen
in the chamber just across the road from
us later on today thanks for now keep
well thank you